Millie Bobby Brown who is the star of
stranger things she's the alien girl or
whatever like the it's not an alien
thing it's like whatever the kind of
spooky telepathic girl in stranger
things uh Millie Bobby Brown has said
that she is a
feminist and she knows she is a feminist
because a psychic told her which to me
totally checks out because
psychics gain their dubious insights by
communing with demons so I'm not
surprised at all that a demon would
encourage anyone to become a feminist uh
in fact I think that's a large driver of
feminism probably you know at least at
least indirectly a lot of people are
laughing they say you get your insights
from a
psychic yeah of course people do because
people have a natural inclination toward
the religious and when they don't
practice true religion religion which is
uh a habit of virtue that inclines the
will to give God what he deserves when
you don't uh follow theology which is
Faith seeking understanding applying
logic and reason to our intuitions of
God and our longing for God then you
become the most superstitious person in
the world and you do the crystals and
the horoscopes and the astrology and the
psychics and the The Vibes man and like
the yoga and the feeling the chakras
with the whatever and you just go into
all this kind of
craziness I I don't want to knock Millie
Bobby bran because she seems actually
pretty promising well she a good actress
good little actress and she's very young
and I believe I don't follow these
things closely but I believe she's
engaged to be married and in this this
interview with her in when she talks
about the psychics in Glamour magazine
she says that what she really wants is
to have kids so I don't know I look at a
young actress in Hollywood and she's
been a child star which is something
that really messes virtually everyone up
and she's nevertheless said I want to
get married at a nice young age not too
young but 19 20 it's pretty good get
married young and start having kids and
I think okay I want to encourage her
that's great that's awesome she's still
surrounded by a bunch of wackos in
Hollywood who might be influencing her
with bad things like feminism and
psychics and whatever but she she
clearly has a a
decent core intuition here so she should
follow that and stop listening to Demons
whether those demons sit in Hollywood
producer offices or whether those demons
are uh communicating via psychic media
right now go to hillsdale.edu are you a
few years or decades out of school and
wondering what the heck did I even learn
and what was the point you might even be
thinking I don't have the time to learn
something new well if that's you you're
not alone and it's not too late
Hillsdale College is offering more than
40 free online courses learn about the
works of CS Lewis the rise and fall of
the Roman Republic or the history of the
ancient Christian church with Hillsdale
College's online courses if you are not
sure where to start check out CS Lewis
on Christianity in this seven lecture
course you will examine some of Lewis's
classic Works including Mere
Christianity the screw tape letters and
the abolition of man you'll also see
what Louis had to say about scripture
prayer suffering Joy Heaven and Hell the
course is self-paced so that you can
start whenever and wherever enroll now
in CS Lewis on Christianity to discover
Lewis's core lessons on Christianity and
how to apply Faith to your life go to
hillsdale.edu to enroll no cost easy to
get started hillsdale.edu NS
hillsdale.edu
I have the least surprising story that
you've ever read in the
news you might recall a couple years ago
Victoria's Secret rebranded Victoria
Secret previously advertised their
lingerie on very sexy women and then
they said we're not going to do that
anymore we're going to uh advertise our
lingerie on very obese people and on and
men and kind of
Butch we're not going to no more sexy
women we're just going to do every other
kind of person including dudes and here
you go here's the big surprise they're
selling less
lingerie a't that weird this all began
because of Megan rapino Megan rapino was
a soccer lady who hated America and she
would pop up in the news when she said
something disparaging about America or
reality or tradition or decency and but
she also happened to play soccer I guess
and so she she blasted Victoria's Secret
and said they were pushing a message
that's really harmful one that was
patriarchal and sexist viewing not just
what it meant to be sexy but what the
clothes were trying to accomplish
through a male lens and through what men
desired and you see Megan rapino was a
lesbian and it's 2023 and everybody's
supposed to be a lesbian and nobody's
supposed to be normal ever and we're
supposed to take the views that were
previously on the kind of fringes of
society and that were a bit eccentric
and those are supposed to be normal and
anyone who has normal desires or
behaviors they should be outcasts they
should be thrown into the outer Darkness
where there's wailing and nashing of
teeth and they should not get their
Victoria Secret catalog with the pretty
ladies in it uh-uh that's very wrong and
sexist and patriarchal and whatever so
then they Rebrand the the company they
don't they don't don't even do the
annual fashion show the annual fashion
show is gone that's been gone for five
years now and they got really good
reviews from the critics this is just
like rotten tomatoes when some liberal
movie comes out and the critics say oh
95% it's amazing it's so beautiful and
it's about you know lesbian Cowboys on a
mountain somewhere and they say oh it's
the greatest movie ever and then the
audience score is like 5% because no one
actually wants to see it because while
it it might press some ideological
buttons that the critics like it's not
actually entertaining and it's not a
good
movie Victoria Secrets projected revenue
for this year is $6.2 billion which is a
lot of money but it's 5% lower than last
year
and it's even lower than the $7.5
billion that it had in Revenue in
2020 that's a big that's a big
difference 7.5 billion down to 6.2
billion in three years that's a collapse
of your
company why
because no amount of activism will ever
change human nature no amount of
activism will ever change the
fundamentals of
reality this is what CS Lewis means when
he when he mocks The
Atheist and he says he's not worried
about atheists because atheists can no
more change God's existence then a
lunatic in his padded
cell can can blot out the Sun by writing
Darkness on the walls of those cell you
just simply don't have the power to do
that
and yet they go on and the renos of the
world and the feminists and the LGBT act
and all the
activists they that's why they scream
that's why they yell and they scream in
the street because their preference is
out of accord with reality and reality
is always going to win and they're
always going to be
frustrated the more you try to deny
reality which is what we've all been
told to do for the last 30 years at
least really the last 50 60 years
hey you're born into a family you hate
that family you're born into a body you
should hate that body you're born into a
country hate that country you're born
with certain natural desires suppress
those desires try to have the opposite
desires that's not going to be a recipe
for flourishing boy what a great clip
that was now h h Huh huh ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nolles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time